here's the article Daily Mail Newt
Gingrich calls for the GOP to expel Matt
gates for being an anti-republican and
slams his childish behavior I'm not a
republican I've never been a republican
I don't like Republicans but I voted for
them in 2020 because of Donald Trump
because of his second term agenda and
because wokeness and the far left and
the Democrats have completely lost their
minds to the point where it's actually
kind of worrying but when Kevin McCarthy
Works secret backroom deals with
Democrats to give him their funding on
Ukraine whatever garbage they want
because they won't just commit to
actually debating bills in Congress
well then you might as well just have
Democrats in control once again
so I look at Matt Gates and the
Coalition he is leading they represent a
new faction of Voters just because GOP
or R is slapped on their title does not
mean we agree or even like the
Republican party so when Newt Gingrich
comes out and says medgate should be
expelled no I I say actually Kevin
McCarthy should be expelled it's this is
all Kevin McCarthy's fault all of it the
shutdown threats him getting him getting
removed from from the speakership
it is not the fault of Matt Gates if
Kevin McCarthy says he wants to be in
charge he wants to be the boss and that
in exchange for leadership he he gives
guarantees and then violates those
guarantees he screwed up nobody else did
well this is huge and this is what the
media does all the time whenever a
person in a particular position of
authority fails to live up to the
obligations that they incurred by
stepping into that position the media
and the establishment blame those who
pointed out that that person failed and
then tried to remove them from their
position for people losing respect in
said position when of course it's the
exact opposite people don't rally behind
removing these people from these
positions in the vast majority of cases
because they themselves decided they
wanted to delegitimize this institution
or position it's because they're not
doing what they're supposed to do so we
saw this when Trump attacked the media
repeatedly for very good reason and the
response was Donald Trump has undermined
American Trust in our institutions and
not these institutions have undermined
trust in themselves and Trump is now
giving a voice to that so similarly
Gates pointing out and doing what he
could to oustic
does not mean that Gates is responsible
for the fact that the American people
have lost faith in that institution or
pushed him out it's really more a
product of uh McCarthy's own actions
catching up to him did Gingrich give any
more reasoning for you know for that you
know in terms of the the need to keep
McCarthy on
did he spell that out in detail because
you know there is this divide between
the stakeholders and the American Empire
and the interests of the people who live
here that is sort of the fault line as I
see it uh in the in the GOP Civil War
you know you have this this Generations
old GOP power base which is tied to the
military it's tied to the energy sector
it's tied to the intelligence services
and these are folks who you know from
oil companies to military contractors
make their money on the expansion and
protection of assets and foreign lands
and sometime around the 90s there became
a a very noticeable cleavage between the
kind of trickle-down economic ideal of
those corporations
sort of spilling into the middle class
to having this kind of divide between
the American Homeland and the Empire
where the people in the Homeland were
suffering as the even as the empire grew
and expanded and what we see right now
in in the Republican Wing is you can
pretty much tell whether or not somebody
voted for or against McCarthy by whether
they represent the foreign policy
establishment or whether they represent
domestic interests the the Democrat
Party is completely corralled on that on
that front there's division on the GOP
my concern with this is
since I don't fully understand the logic
of of the McCarthy back you know why it
is that folks like like Gingrich
um are so are so insistent on it I
wonder if without compromise to that
blob people are afraid of you know
they don't really have a mafia on their
side the bush wing of the Republican
Party
you know I think protects there's a
strong representation in the justice
department and and in the dod and CIA
and state department there's no
represent representation of that in the
in the populist Wing so there's like no
protection against attempts to use dirty
tricks to kill the careers of Republican
you know Congress people so I wonder how
much of that is appeasement because
there is no mob for the the populist
faction of the GOP
well Newt does represent more of a kind
of rhino establishment-based politics
that of course is also connected to many
secret societies and as he previously
even said before the main kind of
problem that a lot of people are seeing
with Trump is that he's not a part of
some of those same secret societies so
what you bring you you bring up a very
interesting point because there are a
lot of populists but there also is a lot
of rhinos a lot of establishment types A
lot of people who go to the Bohemian
Grove take off their clothes worship
Molech and of course have mock child
sacrifices that are the good old boys
the good old Republicans the cons the
Christian conservatives that of course
value traditional uh you know ways which
is which is kind of ridiculous when you
look at the face value of what they're
responsible for because when they had a
seat at the table when when uh when 2001
happened they had everything they had
the Senate they had Congress they had
the presidency they had the American
people behind them and what did they do
they failed at the American people and I
think there's a huge section of uh the
populist that realizes holy cow like
Like These Guys these these guys could
be just as bad as the Democrats here we
have to speak out against this and I I
can understand your kind of sentiments
here but when looking at the current
situation that we're in the left side is
pretty bad the right side it's pretty
bad too so so I think this is the
current predicament that a lot of people
are left in kind of questioning and
wondering uh where do we go from here
either side we go on we're kind of
screwed here and the politicians who are
going to be put into place are going to
be puppets of the establishment that are
going to be doing the screwing it's all
about the interests of those with money
and it always is
they're supposed to be the will of the
people involved in our system but it's
not supposed to be direct democracy but
now we've we've I should say now but
we've been in the system for quite some
time maybe even 100 years where it's
literally just rule by Elites if you
have the money then you make the rules
if you're a regular person your your
ideas don't matter and some may argue
that there's a meritocracy in this like
well if you if you work hard enough and
you're smart enough and you make all
that money well then you will get an
outsized voice it makes sense those of
Merit and capability the problem is the
purpose of our government was that the
opinions of people who work regular jobs
and live humble lives matter as well and
for the longest time they've not
mattered at all in our in our in our
politics
so while I agree you know someone like
Elon Musk they're like how does he have
so much power how does he buy you know X
how does he assert this Authority well
you know he built all these companies he
made lots of money and then he uses that
you know what he built and the resources
he's gathered to have that influence
that's fine I accept that but our our
system of government the the the the
neocon neolib establishment has
basically just said we are fine with not
allowing anyone of humble means to have
a voice period
yeah and the fact that they've
overturned two and a half centuries of
precedent to you know basically charge
Trump with 750 years and Trump is now
winning in the general polls according
to uh Washington Post ABC from I think
Chen euger had like a freak out over
this that they need to be up like 15
points to be able to win in the
Battleground States and just like an
outright General uh ahead uh and you
know the guy is facing 750 years in
prison this was something that we never
even put a toe over that line before and
not just him it's 19 I mean all of his
lawyers they rolled up 19 at once I mean
they basically indicted the entire Inner
Circle uh around that period in January
and you know this is sort of happening
around the globe in democracies at least
around NATO now where it's becoming
shockingly common practice to just ban
your opposition party and you know Imran
Khan arrested bolsonaro they arrested
Marine Le Pen they they arrested salvini
every populist leader there seems to be
an immune system with the foreign policy
establishment that when a populist
leader Rises to power uh for the
interests of the people who live there
rather than the interests of of the
international you know assets that they
hold or resources or Investments then
there is a sort of immune system within
the justice department or within the
National Security State to use dirty
tricks to take them out and there's no
there's been no adaptation the past
several years on the populist side I
mean you can see sentiment Rising but
what is there to protect Matt Gates when
he runs for governor if he starts to win
I mean you can easily imagine you know
Merrick Garland taking him for something
the FBI went after Gates just recently
already and they're investigating him on
a whole bunch of BS ethics garbage and
the the argument they're making is that
Matt Gates is only going after Kevin
McCarthy because McCarthy won't stop the
ethics investigations into Matt Gates
and uh that doesn't seem to make a whole
lot of sense it actually seems inverted
that the reason in their investigations
into Matt Gates is because he has been
continually pushing Back Against the
Machine and refusing to play ball why is
it that so many of the supposed
anti-establishment Republicans all of a
sudden lost their balls and started just
dropping to their knees for Kevin
McCarthy I have to imagine when they
watched his investigations launch into
Matt Gates they said please I'll do
anything you say because the threat of
total Shameless weaponization is now
very much on the table I think that that
it was easier to be emboldened and to
take on the establishment when you
assumed a certain fair play a sort of
you know Mark of the Queensbury type
thing like okay they're gonna rail me in
the press or they're going to go after
my donors not like they're going to
physically lock me up uh and subject me
to tens of millions of dollars of legal
bills uh for you know jaywalking in my
home District yeah well I think a lot of
this is a product of the fact that the
media doesn't have the kind of power
that it's traditionally had so in the
past if they did write those hit pieces
on you if they did smear you if they did
tell the American can people that you
were a big big bad racist then it was
quite possible that your political
career if not uh being entirely over was
going to be in some substantial way
negatively affected by those accusations
but as the American people have woken up
and seen that the entire press apparatus
is controlled by One Singular set of
interests and they're going to do
whatever they can to keep the people who
they're profiting off of being in power
in power and they're going to smear
anyone who's anti-establishment who
stands up to them they've realized okay
this press apparatus isn't actually
working for us the way it used to
because it no longer has legitimacy in
the American people no longer trust it
so what's left after that you actually
have to take legal action in order to
silence dissidents or stop them from
running or affecting any substantial
political change because you're not able
to assassinate them in the court of
public opinion anymore thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows a
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time